bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono cani j oggi proviamo a
fare uniscape room da provare anche in
multiplayer però io non ho amici quindi
lo gioco da solo allora vedo che c'è la
versione normale la versione horror chi
detta non cambia niente se non che più
buio
credo poi lo so ci siamo ragazzi l'ho
fatto normale come vedete la stessa cosa
solo che non è lavoro va bene allora
ragazzi l'unica roba che devo fare è
uscire dalla stanza qui di questa è una
vera e propria skype room non so quanto
ci metteremo vediamo allora c'è il
computer con la tazza vediamo se si
accende qualcosa nel computer non si può
usare peccato davvero che non ha lo devo
c'è un floppy attenzione c'è loro di
telefono telefono cellulare ok che
cacchio vuol dire telefono cellulare
forse mi sta indicando che c'è il t9 da
usare nel telefono devono usare il t9
nel telefono per scrivere che cosa devo
far finta che il telefono sia alti e che
questo telefono sia quello col t9 devo
trovare ragazzi la parola da scrivere
sicuramente non so cosa però c'è un
floppy chissà che cacchio devo scrivo
qua c'è qualcosa d'altro
ma gag e quindi cosa mi rappresenta sta
roba oh mio dio ha forse sono le le le
prime lettere di ogni non lo so provo
prova a vedere che cosa cosa devo
toccare per prima allora maiale partendo
dal basso sono maiale mucca pecora leone
e traguardo maiali mucca pecora leone
traguardo quindi a c'è un 8 abili che ci
sono i numeri nascosti però qua c'è un 8
poi c'è un 8 che cacchio me ne faccio di
un 8
what the fuck ho sbloccato la porta
grazie a tutti grazie grazie mille
questo è un genio sono un genio one ici
giugni tris a fossi fago l'amico ai
segni dicono i numeri quindi in base in
un attenzione come che era allora maiale
no aspetta maiale maiale maiale maiale
ok mucca pecora leone leone vesco
ora è giusto è maiale mucca pecora
allora al contrario le partite partendo
dall'alto e dall'alto perché il
giapponese si legge la destra sinistra
fantastico ma let's go my brothers ma
let's go ma come siamo forti
otranto una chiave una chiave che me la
infilo perché non è dei cosa fare poi
c'è un se sta roba giappone la bandiera
del giappone perfetto abbiamo svezia
giappone e basta peraltro solo due
bandiere non so quante ne devo trovare
qualcosa
be king and a hera per il labirinto di
prima ce l'ho già arrivato perché io io
intelligente io 6 milioni di iscritti
allora prendiamo la chiave e andiamo da
per cui segua servono è sicuro anzi anzi
dovrei riconosceresti simboli
probabilmente sulle pergamene e le
pergamene che sono esattamente 5 perché
sono una due tre quattro cinque perfetto
che siano sono ragazzi per chiamare con
le chiamiamo eccoli li danno cinque
numeri teoricamente non sono belle 5
comunque servono qualcosa adesso capiamo
metto sta chi aveva qualche parte prima
a devono trovare quattro chiavi
minchia va bene c'è il simbolo del
ingroia
quindi niente allora torniamo allora
anzitutto al variare del giappone che la
mettiamo vicino la bandiera della svezia
ok allora abbiamo giappone svezia
spero ci sia anche l'italia dove devo
fare questo ragazzi vedi il numero di
telefono e il numero di telefono
ok ma allora questo è il quadrato
manca il triangolo che non ho idea
perchè non è ok quindi lo risolvere il
sudoku manca al triangolo però cacchio
ecco triangolo e con triangolo regalo
trovato l'ho trovato l'ho trovato l'ho
trovato equa e nel 4 stop esente da
contare carpe volevo portare solo quelle
rosse porca [ __ ] le conteneva tutte
12345678 quale solo rosse sono tre li
mortacci tua
8 o tre penso sia 8 che va beh li
contiamo tutte quindi 28
non mi ricordo più 4 ok 98 94 2894 2894
ok non so però dove metterlo 2894
parliamo qua 2894 vediamo non è questo
2394 però solo con i rossi questo punto
2394 no tu sorella morgan sembra quando
39 46 stavo già correndo dall'altra
parte veloci ma no al telefono mica
enorme
meno male alla specie la seconda la
seconda chiave troppo alla per terra che
si spacca il pavimento se quel la
seconda chiave sta qua siamo a due
chiavi perfetto cosa me ne fotte a una
cosa dietro beta bellissimo sand nude
c'è scritto one files weight c'è scritto
one files to hate 15 dotto to sorella
morta non era non era neanche degli
imposti
pronto vodafone 57 61 hanno messo una
suoneria di mortacci tua
57 61 let's be nice
senza chiave a me guatemala no che
maniera è questo sud africa e sud africa
sudafrica se abbiamo la terza bandiera
abbiamo giappone svezia sudafrica manca
solo una bandiera speriamo sia l'italia
quel punto allora qua la francia ce
l'abbiamo
la francia abbiamo capito che fr ed e 87
ok manca il primo manca di primi due
numeri che lascia la bandiera
dell'europa però non c'è lei è a posto
sarà un deficiente 60 387 tu madre morta
63 86
scusate ragazzi ma ho visto leo
effettivamente c'erano avevo due in
chimica e si vede abbiamo aperto
innanzitutto questa perfetto simbolo
mettiamo assolutamente qui perfetto che
cosa strani chiesta roba messico giallo
mi chiamano visto lo sfondo rega ma che
pirla azzurro sopra e questo sarà
perdere forza e mo ho finito sento
qualcuno che è rotta la luce a noi c'è
un bottone mi chiama il cross diventato
attenzione ciao ragazzi vado in giappone
nuovo no non è vero non è vero nei
cassetti c'è dell'acqua quella terra my
heart linden fire perfetto boogie
wonderland banca banca al vento e manca
al fuoco quindi manca quella rossa
manca al momento posso già te l'ho già
capito che si tratta gli elementi 2000
di quoziente intellettivo ragazzi vanno
posizionati si cosi io che ne so io che
ne so ah ok ok quindi adesso ho capito
allora water wind fire è certo che terra
piatta faida sembra un vulcano wind
quello schizzato e volte nell'ultimo
game
va bene questo come studiate giapponese
confavi j ragazzi questo poi vi spiego
io i kanji allora
quella è la terra perché quello terreno
che questo è il vulcano sembra il fuoco
questo è il vento schizzato ok su per il
tuffo lo scafo le minchiate con la
madonna
la chiave è stato la chiave la porta
proprio entro dove che come torno
indietro cioè pulsante save o mio dio a
dal soffitto proprio la madonna che
esagerazione potevo farci un giro più
easy che ho fatto
c'è una barca c'è la barca fatto
scappare che per il gioco che bel gioco
st 4 dollari
meritatissimi devono ma perché poi la
puoi giocare anche con gli altri unifico
peccato che giovi una volta questa come
profugo un'ora ci ho messo a fa sta roba
1 ora però che gli sia piaciuto ragazzi
e voi non avete visto un ora di video di
casa di dio ma giampiero siccome so che
bisogna ce lo metto io mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale perché sono sono
presenti questo è un problema era e come
sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo video e
ragazzi
[Musica]